time changes you're in a different mood
different environment to never get set
in one idea and think okay that's it you
know there's a million ways to do
something I just always thought that I
was good enough to be working and and
that was kind of a mantra I was
terrified that it you know I didn't want
to be the weak link in a Quentin
Tarantino what's that believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you and I want to see that
great thing that you have inside of you
come out so you can help change the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from actor
Michael Fassbender and my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
four is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
I think you know maybe it's just a
personal thing sort of but perhaps you
guys feel like that as well that you
feel like you always have to sort of you
know get it right all the time with sort
of acting or guess anything in life
really but it's I think so much
important the more important and a way
to fail and to fall flat in your face
and that's really what rehearsal should
be used for you know to really mix it
around to really you know I remember
there was times where you know Danny was
like that's great let's do that again I
was and we were like no let's not you
know because you want to touch in it but
not like over sort of set it in stone
because you know something that works in
rehearsal period two weeks ago and we're
on set shooting that scene today it was
not gonna work again time changes you're
in a different mood different
environment to never get set in one idea
and think okay that's it you know
there's a million ways to do something
and to always keep that sort of
unexpected sort of element to it and so
you know the rehearsals are there to
mess things up and I always felt like I
don't want to get too close to an end
product in the rehearsal I also read
that it happened a little bit later that
you kind of achieved the success that
you were dreaming of and you were you
were around 30 and you were bartending
up until then yeah I know so many
musicians and artists and actors who are
doing that now you know they're hit in
27 28 29 30 31 and they're still
bartending and they're wondering whether
it's ever gonna happen yeah and I'm
wondering what you said to yourself to
keep going when you started feeling like
that - I just always thought that I was
good enough to be working and and that
was kind of a mantra I just the the real
sort of dream was to just make a living
out of it you know that I could sort of
make a living out of acting and didn't
have to do jobs in the sight
and yeah I just knew you know having
seen what was out there and what I could
do I just knew that I was good enough to
be working and I would get an
opportunity at some point and it should
just be very alive to that opportunity I
think that's something that's so key I
mean it's all luck really I mean it's 95
percent luck you know to be in the right
place I have to know there's a lot of
people that did that helped me be in the
position I'm in today and would not be
here without them that's absolutely key
and clear to me but being alive to when
an opportunity is there and taking it I
think is is very important being being
ready for success when it comes well you
know just for example one hunger came my
way and it was an opportunity to get a
lead role and I knew that I was getting
a chance here and that I had to really
sort of grab it and take it because who
knows when the next opportunity would
come again if it did you know at all so
this quentin's set a party compared to
the other shows you know it he seems so
light but you know he is you know I mean
he's perfectionist so you Darrin come to
work on prepared you know mmm he doesn't
want you to come as an actor and say
okay what do you want me to do you know
he wants you to come to the table with
your homework done and he definitely you
know as you out there I was out there
five six weeks before I stepped in front
of the camera mm-hmm doing my prep work
I had this sort of obviously I'm sort of
you know putting a British accent on and
then the German side of it I mean I
understand German I can speak German but
it was pretty rusty my German so I had
to you know I have to sort of get that
in shape mm-hmm and then you know just
sort of not you know I was terrified but
it you know I didn't want to be the weak
link in a Quentin Tarantino film so you
know it was a I had I had I had my
preparation to do for sure you know
watched a lot of sort of George Sanders
films the early Saints movies right and
just sort of
I tried to sort of pick sort of nuances
and study the way sort of people talked
and moved in the 30s and the use of prop
seemed very elegant sort of lighters and
cigarette cases and tried to sort of
surround myself with those those props
and you know possessions that they would
have had and just sort of like the way
that they held themselves mm-hmm things
like that how have you handled
situations in the past where you felt
like a director who wasn't opening up to
you or wasn't inviting you into the
process do you just kind of grin and
bear it or do you speak up I think so I
think a lot of the times actors like to
talk because they're afraid of getting
up there and doing it you know and I put
myself in that category so I generally
just try to do stuff without telling
them it's more fun as well you know when
you show them something without sort of
having told them you can see them going
well what was that or them going what
was that but you know it's it's it's I
think it's more fun again it's sort of
you know what do they would they would
you know because you can talk about
something and you know for as long as
you want but if you just sort of get up
on his feet and it's not showing or it's
not reading then it doesn't really
matter so I always think just sort of
showing is the best way I think you know
human beings were kind of complex and
our relationships and I like to play
characters that don't hold answers for
audience and I don't like to sort of be
on any moral crusade in terms of sort of
how I present characters I just want to
present them in a provocative way
meaning sort of with all the sort of
bells and whistles as opposed to you
know the more sort of comfortable or
pleasing elements of personality to try
and sort of cover all of this for the
fair that the whole sort of medium of it
all and that way
audiences leave the theater and they
have a conversation and they sort of
question things and it provokes thought
so what inspired you to be an actor in
the first place um lack of options and
laziness no no it was I I didn't really
know what I was going to do
I was 17 and that's cool and then this
guy that was a former pupil at the
school had went to drama school and he
came back and he just started doing
these workshops mm-hmm
and I just went to them and I just
really sort of got hooked after that
advanced roof realized then that's what
I was gonna sort of go on and do
do you like the disappearing or do you
like the play or what's the you know I
don't know I think I just sort of felt
like a it was something that felt right
and comfortable in the way that I said
could express myself you know creatively
mm-hmm I really wanted to sort of be a
guitar or lead guitar player and like a
heavy metal band you know when I was 15
I really sort of went at that all guns
blazing for a couple of years and then I
realized it just didn't reveal I didn't
have this sort of you know the chops for
it so then I came across acting and it
just felt really you know I felt at home
comfortable in it physicality and
performance is always something that's
very important to me it's something that
I would be sort of thinking about
immediately how the character moves
what kind of sort of you know is the car
is the character weighty or is it is the
character light on it's on his feet and
how you can sort of really tell you know
tell an inner life story of the
character through the physicality it's
very helpful and so sometimes you can
express so much more through your sort
of body language and movement then you
know a page dialogue hunter who's 11
wants to know what kind of advice can
you give an 11 year old like me who's
just starting who's in the second year
in the industry
and what keeps you motivated with all
the rejection you're 11 by the way I
think I'll be getting advice off you in
a couple of years so you know I think as
well just have fun you know just have
fun with it you know it should be fun
and and unfortunately you know I think
you know rejection is just part and
parcel of it you know it's a good thing
rejection because it does teach you how
to get that little bit stronger and just
know that well that was an experience
and you'll just move on and you learn
from it and take things from those
moments you know and also you know
fact you know they could be looking for
somebody with red hair or you know two
feet taller or whatever happened to them
that day there's so many things that are
out of your control I think just
concentrate on the scene
what it's about what you're doing you
know where are you coming from where are
you going what are you trying to get in
the scene all those little things that
are about the scene that'll take away
the fear the nerves concentrating okay
where if I just come from if I come from
the store did I buy an ice cream and the
way to this place before I arrived
how does this person in the room that
I'm doing the scene with make me feel
what do I want from them how do I go
about getting what I want from them all
those things will take away all the sort
of nerves and the fear and and then you
just do your thing and as long as you do
your thing and enjoy it then you've done
your job then they'll be picking you for
whatever reasons they'll they will be or
not and but you've done your thing well
yeah I got the script for hunger and I
thought you know wow I was like I write
you know the first act is so sparse and
there's hardly any dialogue at all and I
thought okay this is this is something
you know different and then the second
act came in and then there's that all
sort of Cascade of dialogue going on and
I thought oh well you know this is
another sort of shift and and then I
thought well who really can handle this
script I did think it was a mazing
script that ended it rolled but I was
like can it be brought to fill you know
and then I went to meet Steve and as
soon as I met Steve I was like I've got
to work with him I'm definitely gonna
learn something from him I just got a
real powerful sense of he's you know he
has a real empathy and there's a really
humane quality about him he's a genius
and I just sort of knew that I was in
the presence of something special so
when you read a script like that I mean
the the challenge for you as an actor is
not the thing like okay I'm gonna do it
no matter what kind of director it is
because this is such a great challenge
for me as an actor or know you know I
mean it's a combination of the two
things just what you said you know I
base my decisions on the script and then
the director and if I haven't seen any
of the directors work or it's a first
time director I'll meet them and then
I'll sort of get a vibe off them and
think can i you know you know that was
pretty heavy material hunger it's like
guys spreading extra mint in the wall
starving themselves to death for an hour
and a half I thought it had to be in
very specific hands and I'd seen so many
films about the troubles in Northern
Ireland before that I didn't think did
justice to the topic so and of course
you know I had the whole weight change
and you know there was a lot of sort of
commitment involved in it so I wanted to
make sure that it was in the right hands
mm-hmm and as soon as I met him I was
like for sure this guy's gonna do
something interesting
I can't died though that was like one of
the times when I was sort of out of work
as an actor I would set myself total
challenges and one of them was was
diving off the the high thing I don't
know it's like you know whatever ten
meters high this was when I was 23
he's like last week and and I was up
there and I was kind of like you know
going to the edge and then sort of
backing out and then these kids came up
and they were like jumping off sideways
in all sorts of ways so I was standing
on the side next thing the kids came
back up again and they were like I don't
know like 10 11 and and and one of the
kids came over to me he's like you
haven't jumped off yet it's like first
time you jump off you're gonna get hurt
a little bit it won't be as bad as you
think so I took his advice and I dived
off and it did hurt I kind of went in a
little bit like that I didn't fully
commit so it kind of hurt my leg did you
slap it on the water after that I was
like I was up and down the stairs I was
going I kept jumping up he was right
listen to the children listen to the
children sound effects I always sort of
like I don't know have a thing about
doing it's almost like an OCD thing even
to like you know those things where you
would press the walk sign you know I've
just rented a Harley Davidson for the
first time
I like this bird I think that's a robin
redbreast formula one I followed okay so
it's like
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Melissa O'Brien
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson are you going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leaving
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Michael Lamott from chart
your trade Michael thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and taking the picture and posting
it on Twitter I really appreciate your
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the book thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
hunger broke you in so many ways as a
star and you work all day I haven't hear
the Sunday Times described just a great
one of the great European actors of his
generation that you know the praise that
came and the awards that came with that
Michael a did they sit easy with you do
they you know are you okay with them
because it's a sense of the build the
build I mean well yeah you know it's
sort of like yeah most of the time you
know it's like Jesus you know managed to
sort of get away with another one you
know it's like and you know you're
always sort of you know expecting I
don't know a fall when stuff like that I
just don't really read that much to be
honest in general no I don't really you
know I don't I don't read that I don't
read the store views or anything like
that I was working with an actor at you
know when I was sort of doing some stage
and and he was sort of well-established
and he said to me you know if you live
by the sword you die by the sword
yeah like you know the no coward as well
I think said you know if you believe the
good reviews you have to believe the bad
ones yes and you know it's gonna sort of
become a distraction as well so at this
point are you looking to push yourself
harder are you looking to mix up the you
know the commercial on the not so
commercial because yeah you know the
balance between the two is ideal for me
and I'm always trying to yeah I'm always
you know trying to push myself and take
risks and try and challenge myself and
try and not stay in a comfort zone if
you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]